[Music]
i almost got married once
there were no two souls more in rhythm
than wentworth and i
and i was persuaded by my family to give
him up
my father exquisite jawline he's never
met a reflective surface he didn't like
and my sisters
i'm just too kind and that's my problem
i give all of my attention to others and
then i suffer for it
where are your children how should i
know i would have been a far happier
woman and keeping him than i have been
and giving him up it's been seven years
eight darling at some point you have to
move on
there'll be special guest time gallant
captain wentworth is it true he's
devastatingly handsome
[Music]
look at me i'm captain wentworth and i
am handsome uh captain meet man actually
we
met matt
your face has matured your hair remains
intact your hair is also suitably
appropriate
you still have jam on your face
now we're worse than axes
we're friends
perfect
for me i think i'm in your way perhaps
you can correct that can i help you with
something considering what i'd like help
with probably not do i sense a romance
brewing he must be after something why
is it suspicious
i am willing to work for my titles
imagine my luck a flirt and a hard
worker i don't get rich
how is it that life without warning
become flooded with so much newness
i broke his heart
i don't want you to be hungry what would
you want me to be
i know how much she values your
friendship
i didn't know if i'd ever see you again
or if you knew how much i cared time
makes many changes i'm not yet so much
changed
don't let anyone
tell you how to live
or who to love
[Music]
[Music]
you